foreign
[Music]
on May 5th the last part of James Gunn's
Guardians of the Galaxy opened in
theaters and the story of our heroes
came to an end and what an ending it was
with volume 3 the story around the
raccoon rocket Peter Quill AKA Star-Lord
the tree like being Groot Gamora mantis
Drax and nebula was brought to a proper
close many tears were shed and not just
in the film it was obvious beforehand
that not every character may say goodbye
to the franchise but after the brilliant
ending of Guardians 3 we can now start
making some predictions so in case you
weren't able to make it to the
post-credits scene or your eyes were
just too watery we've summarized the
whole ending of Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 for you in this video however be
warned as this can't be done without
massive spoilers of course
what certainly surprised many after all
the speculation before the release is
that James Gunn has Let each of the
Guardians survive a lot of rumors were
circulating about the death of Drax
since the actor Dave Batista has
declared his departure from Marvel in
addition we also had the theory that
quill or rocket would sacrifice
themselves but as usual with James Gunn
things turned out very differently than
expected and following the final battle
against the high evolutionary the
guardian simply parted ways
it all starts with Peter who finally
wants to face his past on Earth after
many years so he sets out to visit his
grandfather who is already over 90 years
old but still alive but a comeback of
Star-Lord is as good as certain because
as could be seen after the post-credits
scene it said that the legendary
Star-Lord will return the fact that he
might head back to Earth was teased over
and over again during the film before
that he was mainly busy mourning the
nugamora since these two will probably
no longer become a couple going back to
his home is also only logical now of
course speculation begins as to when and
how he will celebrate his comeback our
guess here is of course the movie
Avengers the King Dynasty even though we
won't have anything to do with the new
Avengers it's still possible that it
would come out of retirement for the
final battle against the super villain
mantis also leaves on her own Quill's
sister wants to finally find herself
after the death of ego and her dates
with the Guardians so she sets off with
her three tamed analysts while mantis's
character is grown over the course of
the movies her story seems to have ended
as well whether we'll see her again
remains to be seen so far though there
is no scenario where we can well imagine
her in a future film
nebula and Drax set out on their Journey
as a couple they want to take care of
the children created by the high
evolutionary of nowhere a return of the
two seems actually impossible while
nebula has become more and more mature
as mother and good voice of the group
Drax also became increasingly aware of
his true identity as the film progressed
as stated in the film Drax the Destroyer
became Drax the father
even though we had speculated that there
would be a comeback for Gamora and quill
we were proven wrong Gamora seems to
have really found her new family in the
ravagers now thus a return on her part
also seems out of the question actress
Zoe Saldana did already reveal in
interviews that this was her last
Guardians movie
of course things will get exciting with
rocket he and his origin story were
after all the main part of the film
since the Galaxy will always need its
Guardians he ended up being named their
new captain we finally got to meet his
new team in the mid-credit scene not
only do we see that his beloved music
will continue to be a part of the
Guardians the new Squad is also made up
of familiar faces Groot is now kingroot
so even bigger and stronger than we've
ever seen him in the scene he resembles
more a boulder than a tree cragland
stays as well after finally being able
to control yandu's Arrow of course Cosmo
can't leave aside also joining them is
Adam Warlock his role was one of the
most interesting new additions to the
film beforehand many have already
wondered how this can go well to cast
Adam Warlock with Will Poulter but James
Gunn surprised us yet again and turned
him into a villain who doesn't want to
be evil at all
in the end we are left with the young
girl that the Guardians freed from the
clutches of high evolutionary she seems
to have similar powers to Captain Marvel
as we could see from the beams of energy
on her hands there are already rumors
about her being the character of
philavel known from the comics she is
the daughter of Marvel and later becomes
Captain Marvel herself
whether we will see the Guardians again
in one or another constellation remains
unclear so far it just seems too
unlikely that Disney could entrust this
project to anybody other than James Gunn
with the conclusion of part three it
seems that at least the chapter about
the previous Heroes is closed we can't
wait to see what the future holds the
MCU is big and the outer space with all
its planets aliens and spaceships is an
exciting setting should there be any new
Guardians films at some point however it
will probably never be the same as it
was with Star-Lord and his friends
so that's the end of Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 recap for you what are your
thoughts are we going to see our heroes
on the big screen again and do you even
want them to or is it really about time
for their successors let us know your
views in the comments
[Music]